each member of the madrigal family from
disney's encanto is given a gift that
reflects their personality and can be
used to help the community yet not all
of the madrigal's gifts are equally
useful many adults will notice this
seems to be especially true with
mirabelle's aunt peppa who has been
given the miraculous power to control
the weather while this would normally be
an incredible gift peppa isn't like
storm from x-men who can summon rain and
wind at will instead she's a bundle of
emotions whose mood is reflected in the
weather she conjures as a result
throughout incanto peppa is seen with
clouds hovering above her head
signifying the anxiety she seems to feel
almost constantly peppa's gift is well
suited to her stressed out personality
given how deep her emotions seem to run
however it appears peppa hasn't managed
to harness her feelings in a way that
enables her to turn her gift to anyone's
advantage she's honestly kind of a wreck
and that's something most kid viewers
probably didn't notice but the adults
watching sure did